so next round bot like christian
grandmaster he my
so
to 280 well
obviously yes g6 a bit stupid
sequence of moves
ok why play with c4
and then
create some kind of funny reversed benoni
if ​​black moves by that black can of
course also play six or c6
or take well let's see  what he
does
with the four
comes the most actually ok one
way
we want the dirt i'll try to get
the dirt back with dispensers a3
or can now 15 ok was that well
tried on this old one i
never thought so we have a look
yes he stays  while who wants to keep it with b5
the thing well i could already ag
what pulls because then the one from c4
looks terrible
well i'll tell you
if it had to go back completely
actually okay the
4 h 65 yes something similar there is
though  in the slightly better form
actually for black good 465
takes takes there
spinner c4 such
a similar position exists in
theory with six  bishops 7 stood with g6
good g6 is of course not implausible in view of
the weakness on the four,
but
you still sometimes know the 14
so that was superior the four devious d40
found the four of the six ministers to be a
good endgame he quickly
decided that  i jump now i can
go 5 in
general you always ask yourself where the
black king wants to go
the development isn't that great
knight f6 would i have now jump e5
then maybe queen a4 was there still the
five maybe it could come
yes that should actually be nice says
springer h 6
so the question is whether you
can maybe get active with springer r5
wearing
i do that
on the b8 runner 4 should also be
an idea because i5 definitely
don't want to play i
that it would be so terrible but that's how it works
you're actually
okay
so now maybe thome 1 and energie
four now maybe my ideas too
has two die he'll come anyway
now i actually thought i can
just take e5 whereby of course the
figures then look a bit
stranded runner runner tours so that
seven my idea hangs a lot also
somehow looks a bit
inharmonious well but another world also very
funny
so i threaten to turn in now  something
strange c5
do the five what does he draw then
when the four
let’s see what comes
then the queen has been
sacrificed set
whatever such a knight like that exchange
is on the four a bit badly strong
something you have to
play a lot more then it’s simple  it does
n't help a bit with
maybe
a jumper like that so you know the king faisal and toom er eight and a half binding of the current a v8
so i would like to go to f8
good field
maybe then three with which he also hangs the
lady f8
still on the 7th
i could move it now because
king 46 has come several times he will probably play  n
have to or are of course already a
bit tense out of why could
I give you
68 king 46
is not possible
I can swap about eight times in the
direction of
FC then somehow have three to four
more pawns well
the strongest was definitely not but
res 1 has  enough he must of course
really lost
but you could still fight okay